เฮ
Olá,
pessoal. Muito bem-vindos à nossa live
semanal.
E agora acabei de perceber que eu só
coloquei o link, eu acredito, da versão
para TV
e para
também
computador. Deixa eu colocar também o
link do celular para vocês.
Quem quiser assistir do celular fica
melhor. Um minuto só.
H,
pronto. Essa é a versão do celular.
Versão para celular. Tô escrevendo no
grupo.
Vou colocar aqui também para quem tiver
acompanhando,
tá? Essa é a versão para celular.
Bem, pessoal, vamos continuar então
aqui. Vamos apresentar as perguntas de
hoje. Mas antes, boa noite, Vilma. Boa
noite Cleidan. Alice Vogel. Boa noite
Carlos, Célia, Rosâela,
Edleusa,
Denise Blunk,
Alessandra
Paz.
Muito bem, pessoal. Vamos as perguntas
do dia.
Ah, fala nisso, a
Alice Vog tá perguntando sobre Portugal,
né? Muito bem. Portugal foi excelente,
foi maravilhoso, congresso excelente
e
tive
a grande felicidade de ter sido seoneado
aí pela uma pessoa maravilhosa, seu
Mário, que é namorado Alice Voger, viu
Alice Vog? Tenho muita gratidão aí pelo
pela
pelo carinho, tá, do Mário e pela
gentileza maravilhosa dele, tá? E os
presentes também.
Bem, vamos lá, pessoal.
Como faz para reverter esteatose
hepática
com suplementos? Já estou na academia e
fazendo a dieta carnívora da selva.
Bem, muito interessante que você já
esteja fazendo a dieta carnívora, que
esteja treinando, parabéns por isso,
pois isso afasta justamente
os agentes inflamatórios que vão gerar e
agravar esteatose. Em relação aos
suplementos, a literatura recente mostra
ômega-3 em altas doses, 4 g diários,
tanto com epa quanto DHA, um total,
reduz significativamente a gordura
hepática, melhora a sensibilidade
insulina no fígado,
especialmente quando você consegue
aumentar o DH em pelo menos 2% nos gólos
vermelhos.
Além disso, eu recomendo a cimarina, que
vocês conhecem bem, né? extrato do cardo
mariano numa dose efetiva também o ácido
alfaalipoica, muito interessante, os
tocotrienois do urucum,
os probióticos de qualidade para
restaurar a microbiota, vitamina D em
níveis adequados.
Só tome cuidado, quando for tomar outros
tocotrienois, não utilize os o tocoferol
artificial, tá? Que é o alfa tocoferol,
tá? Porque uso de alfotocoferoló em
altas doses
tem limitações em diabéticos,
pode gerar problemas.
Muito bem, vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Minha esposa está com Eu falei que
dificuldade, ó. Minha esposa está com
candidase recorrente, um tratamento para
minha esposa.
Muito bem. Vamos fazer aqui umas
orientações para ajudar. O protocolo
mais eficaz,
eh, se a sua esposa tá com uma saúde boa
do fígado,
é realmente parar o açúcar, os alimentos
processados, industrializados,
refinados.
E se o fígado dela tiver muito bem, você
pode est instituindo o fluconasol,
150 mg semanais.
OK?
Isso vai ser interessante.
Agora, isso pode ser muito problemático
para várias pessoas que estão com fígado
já gorduroso ou que estão com algum
problema no fígado.
Aí você pode estar utilizando também
o clutrimasol
vaginal, tá? 500 mg semanal ou ácido
bórico. Esse aqui é um dos que eu mais
gosto. O ácido bórico em óvulos vaginais
é muito bom.
Então, como eu disse, é muito importante
eliminar o açúcar, eliminar o glúten, os
láxos da dieta,
incluir os probióticos de alta potência.
Você pode usar até óvulo vaginal de
probiótico. Isso é bem interessante.
Também pode utilizar óvulo vaginal de
ácido caprílico, né, derivado do óleo de
coco ou o próprio óleo de coco.
Isso é bem interessante também para
matar o fungo de maneira natural. Pode
usar os óleos essenciais, né, de
tem o de melaleuca e tem também o de
orégano que tem ação fúngica.
Então tem bastante coisa dá para fazer,
tá? Mas o principal é cortar o açúcar,
cortar os alimentos refinados,
industrializados.
Vamos paraa próxima pergunta.
Olá, doutor. Muito obrigado por nos
transmitir tão valioso o conhecimento.
Estou com neuropatia nas pernas, já não
sinto os pés devido diabetes,
o que poderia me ajudar nessa situação.
Grande abraço, tá? É muito importante a
gente poder te ajudar, tá?
A neuropatia
diabética pode ser reversível dependendo
do tempo de
que ela está instalada, tá? Mas alguns
casos podem não ser reversíveis,
mas a gente pode melhorar muito os
quadros, tá? E e melhorar também
bastante a qualidade de vida.
O primeiro passo é você controlar muito
bem esse açúcar, muito rigorosamente.
Estão cortando todos açúcares, alimentos
processados, refinados,
industrializados, as farinhas,
eliminando também os demais alimentos
inflamatórios, como glúten, derivados do
leite, que vão causar inflamação
intestinal e vão prejudicar a absorção
de nutrientes essenciais.
E também precisa garantir níveis
adequados de vitamina B12, vitamina D,
iniciar ácido alfalipoico também bem
interessante. O alfalipôico é muito bom
para neuropatia,
a dose 600 mg ao dia. A benfotiamina é
muito boa paraa neuropatia também do
diabético, tá? Bfutiamina na faixa de
200 mg por dia.
A luz infravermelha associada à
fisioterapia também reduz de maneira
significativa a dor, melhora quidade de
sono.
Combinar exercícios de fortalecimento,
exercícios aeróbicos é muito bom para
aumentar a massa muscular e aumentar a
sensibilidade insulina, aumentar a
captação de glicose pelas células,
especialmente as musculares.
Investigue a sua saúde intestinal,
pois assim no intestino permeável ou
hiperpermeável
prejudica a absorção dos nutrientes
necessários paraa regeneração.
Se a sua neuropatia for dolorosa,
existe aí também creme de capsaicina que
pode ajudar bastante, tá?
Pode usar o DMSO também junto com a
capsaicina para metabsorção.
Lembrar de repor o cromo na forma de
picolinato, que é muito importante aí
para
ajudar na resistência insulínica,
tá bom? Tem bastante coisa dá para
fazer, tá bom? Você está ao vivo,
Ricardo?
Boa noite, Dr. Alan. Estou com
dificuldades
para encontrar lotar de lítio nos sites
confiáveis. Iurb.com tem, tá? Mas
encontrei aspartato de lítio no IERB,
mas tem orotato também. Tem orotato lá.
Seria a mesma coisa? Não, exatamente,
tá? Mas sim, o aspartato pode ser uma
alternativa.
Então a questão aí principal é o
transportadorato,
lítio e tá ligado ácido orótico. É uma
molécula natural produzida pelas
mitocôndrias e oferece melhor
biodisponibilidade, melhor transporte
celular. O asparto, ele também funciona
como transportador, mas estudos mostram
que ele tem absorção menos eficiente e é
mais difícil de dosar de forma precisa.
Então, se você encontrou 5 mg de
aspartato de lítio, essa dose está
dentro da faixa fisiológica. Então você
pode usar com segurança,
vai usando por enquanto as patatas, já
que você encontrou, mas até onde eu sei,
você consegue num herb também o orotato,
tá? Então, futuramente você pode estar
utilizando o rotato de lítio,
porque ele a longo prazo tem mais
segurança e tem resultados melhores, tem
maior biodisponibilidade.
Certo, meu querido?
É verdade que a carne quando congelado
por muito tempo, em especial a moída de
hambúrguer, pode desenvolver estamina?
Qualquer alimento que é guardado por
muito tempo na geladeira pode acumular
est, tá?
Mas vamos a nuances.
A estamina ela não se forma no
congelador em si, mas sim durante o
processo de deterioração
anterior ao congelamento. Então, se você
congelar a carne quando ela ainda está
fresca, com baixos níveis de estamina, o
congelamento desacelera ou para a
proliferação das bactérias que vão gerar
estamina. O problema ocorre quando a
carne foi armazenada em temperatura
inadequada antes de ser congelada.
permitindo que as bactérias, como é o
caso da Morganela, Morgani, e outras que
produzem
estamina através da descarbo
descarboxilação da estidina possam agir.
OK?
E a estamina, ela é termostável. O que
que significa isso? Ela
não é eliminada através de nem de
congelamento, nem de aquecimento.
A carne moída é especialmente
problemática.
porque ela tem maior área de superfície
exporta, né, por ter sido picada, né,
moída, né? Então isso facilita a
colonização.
Portanto, o ideal é congelar a carne
logo após a compra ou preparo em
temperatura próxima a 0º e consumi-la
dentro de um período razoável. Então,
quando você pega o alimento, por
exemplo, cozinha, come e os e o resto
que sobrou você põe na geladeira,
é óbvio que esse resfriamento não vai
ser perfeito e vai acontecer da bactéria
continuar degradando esse alimento e aí
vai acumular estamina, tá? Então,
geralmente comida com três dias de
geladeira já tem bem mais estamina do
que a comida fresca, certo? Eu não
recomendo carnes moídas, estocadas,
mesmo congeladas por períodos muito
longos, sem monitorar as condições de
armazenamento
anteriores, né? Então, se você tiver
intolerância à estamina ou símbolo de
ativação mastostária, é melhor comer
carnes frescas, tá? Uma vez eu fui comer
uma carne maturada num restaurante até
chique. Passei mal demais porque eu
tenho um certo grau de tolerância
estamina. Então f comi essa carne
maturada, fiquei podre. Então tome
cuidado.
Qual que é o melhor exame para avaliar o
nível de magnésio? Magnésio
intraeleritrocitário. Já falei isso em
vários vídeos, tá? Que que é isso? É o
nível de magnésio dentro da célula
vermelha da emácia.
dentro do glóbulo vermelho, tá? Que vai
refletir a quantidade de magnésio
intracelular. Porque o magnésio do
sangue, o sérico, ele é bem mais comum,
obviamente, mais acessível, mas só 1%
desse magnésio total tá no sangue, a
maioria tá dentro da célula. Ele não vai
refletir com precisão o magnésio sérico
os níveis reais de magnésio no
organismo, OK?
Então, procure por esse exame magnésio
intraeritrocitário
ou eritrocitário, né, que é a mesma
coisa.
É bom fazer os dois juntos, né? Fazer o
célico e fazer o errocitário. Se você
não tem acesso ao magnésio
elitrocitário, uma coisa você pode fazer
também é considerar a questão dos
quartis, né? Se o magnésio tiver no
primeiro ou segundo quartilo, você pode
considerar como a deficiência de
magnésio.
Muitas pessoas que têm sintomas de
deficiência de magnésio, seria fraqueza,
câbra, arritmia,
podem ter níveis no sangue séricos
normais de magnésio. Então, por isso que
é importante medir o errocitário, tá
bom?
Alguns casos pode ser importante também
analisar o magnésio na urina em 24
horas, especialmente quem tá fazendo
protocolo de vitamina D em altas doses,
OK?
Ou para quem tem pé do rim também é
importante ver isso. Qual o melhor
magnésio ou fitoterápico para cálculo
renal?
Melhor magnésio, qualquer magnésio de
alta absorção, né? Você pode usar o
magnésio glicina, você pode usar
o se trato de magnésio de se a pessoa
não tiver diarreia, tá?
E
mas assim, classicamente se usa o
citrato de magnésio, tá?
Mas dá para usar qualquer outra forma de
magnésio queelado.
Teve um estudo clássico de 82, né? Já
tem muito tempo. Ele demonstrou uma
redução de 10 vezes na formação de
cálculos. Us do magnésio, 85% dos
pacientes ficando sem pedras após 3
anos,
tá? Então você pode usar o magnésio de
glicina ou glicinato ou bisglicinato,
que é a mesma coisa, o magnésio de
malato
e utilizar
na forma aí de magnésio queelado,
equivalente a 350 a 500 mg do essencial
por dia. E aí você divide em duas
tomadas, longe das refeições, de
preferência.
Uma
vantagem você utilizar a combinação do
magnésio queelado com o magnésio na
forma de citrato
e também usar o citrato potássio junto,
é que o citrato de potássio ele se liga
ao oxalato de cálcio na urina e previne
o crescimento dos cálculos. Então usa
essa combinação. Se trato de potássio,
se trato de magnésio, mais magnésio
queelado. Isso é uma boa combinação.
Fitoterápico seria o indicato. O
indicado seria o quebra-pedra, que o
nome científico me fugiu agora aqui, mas
é o chade quebra-pedra.
Tá bom?
Deixa eu olhar aqui rapidamente qual que
é o o a planta do quebra-pedra.
Gente, eu tô me bateu um cansaço agora
que eu acabei de jantar. Acho que eu não
devia ter jantado antes da live, que eu
voltei de voo hoje de manhã, dei uma
cochilada de 2 horas em casa
e trabalhar a tarde inteira. Noite é
também à noite, né? Começo da noite.
É filantos niruri, tá? É o nome da
planta. Filantos Niruri.
Mas hoje só temos 12 perguntas, então a
gente vai poder encerrar mais cedo.
Qual que é a sua opinião com relação à
medicação atenta? Minha psicanalista
recomendou
e eu dar uma olhada nessa opção para
TDAH, pensar demasiado estresse e sempre
procuro pelas opções naturais, mas eu
gostaria de saber sua opinião, já que
médios tradicionais quase nunca
consideram os efeitos negativos. Outra
pergunta seria: "Minha mãe teve fé
cromocitoma? Seria essa também um fator
de risco para eu usar a medicação?
Bem, eu sempre procuro evitar esses
medicamentos que têm a estrutura química
muito parecida com afetamina, tá?
O atenta é o inibidor de recaptação de
noreprinefrina.
Ele é menos estimulante que a ritalina,
mas ainda carrega uma carga considerável
de efeitos colaterais que os
tradicionais, como você mesmo falou, os
médicos convencionais ou ortodoxos. Não
é tradicional porque a gente chama de
medicina tradicional, é a medicina
indiana e uveda, tá? Então vamos chamar
de médicos convencionais ortodoxos.
Então esses remédios aí, como é o caso
do atenta, dá muita náusea, pera de
apetite, ansiedade, alteração de humor,
tá? Então na verdade aumenta a
ansiedade, não reduz, não, tá? Dá
problema de sono,
pode tanto insônia quanto sonolência
excessiva, retenção urinária, disfunção
erétil, pode ter até problema de
comportamentos agressivos. Então, antes
de qualquer medicação, eu recomendaria
você utilizar LTAN, magnésio,
reposição de vitaminas e minerais, tá? E
tentar investigar a causa da raiz TDH.
Muitas vezes isso daí é por conta de
alimentação inflamatória, excesso de
açúcar e também excesso de exposição às
redes sociais,
né? Então, esse pensamento excessivo
muitas vezes vem das redes sociais, tá?
E pode vir também de estresse crônico,
inflamação sistêmica por vários motivos,
por outras doenças que podem causar
inflamação sistêmica. Deficiência de
ferro, deficiência de zinco, deficiência
de B6, ômega-3, problemas de intestino,
problema de microbiota intestinal,
tá? Então é importante investir num som
de qualidade, gerenciamento do stress,
sabe? Eliminar as companhias tóxicas.
Eliminar excesso de rede social, de
estímulo audiovisual,
eliminar alimentos inflamatórios,
fazer exercício físico é muito
importante para controlar isso também.
Quanto a fé cromostoma,
eh,
teria que só descartar se você tem
qualquer chance de ter essa doença,
porque eu acho muito improvável que
fêmeocromocintoma geralmente não é uma
doença assim de passar de pai para
filho, tá? Ou de mãe para filha.
Então, mas dá uma investigada, vê as
noreprinefrinas urin as cateculaminas
urinárias, perdão, e acéricas,
porque o atenta, como ali aumenta a
nurrinefrina no cérebro,
ele pode subir a pressão arterial, é um
efeito colateral comum e se você tivesse
algum tipo de f cromocitoma, seria
arriscado. Então, mas aí eh você vê as
os as ccolaminas urinárias e sanguíneas
e descarta isso daí, OK?
Geralmente é o exame de catecolaminas
urinárias de 24 horas e metanefrina do
sangue.
Então, seria imprudente você tomar um
remédio que a metanolpinefrina sem
investigar isso primeiro, tá bom? Apesar
de ser raro isso passar de pai para
filho ou de mãe para filha.
Qual que é minha opinião sobre a vacina
contra o câncer?
Veja bem, a gente não tem como ter muita
opinião porque isso tá em fase de
estudos, né? Isso aí uma coisa que tá só
a nível de pesquisa praticamente, tá? Os
resultados que estão sendo divulgados,
obviamente vocês vão imaginar, são
considerados promissores, mas isso é só
papel, né? A gente não viu na prática.
Então, tem alguns estudos sendo
realizados na Universidade de da Flórida
com uma vacina que, infelizmente, com a
tecnologia de RNA mensageiro,
combinando com imunoterapia
e dizem que estão conseguindo regressão
de tumores
em modelos resistentes,
sabe? Mas isso aí vai ser caríssimo
quando for lançado, mas pode ter um
monte de efeito que a gente nem sabe o
que vai acontecer, tá bom?
A maioria dos testes ainda tá sendo
feita em Camundongos, tem poucos estudos
clínicos e humanos.
A Rússia soltou umas notícias aí
polêmicas que o pessoal achou que era
conversa cascata, né, e não foram
exatamente ainda confirmados.
E eu fico muito preocupado com essa
tecnologia de RNA mensageiro, né? Já
vimos que aconteceu recentemente aí.
E na verdade o que tá sendo divulgado e
tá um pouco confuso é que isso daí na
verdade é para tratar câncer, tá? Não é
para prevenir câncer, não. Se nome
vacina engana, né?
Então como é que você faz uma verdadeira
prevenção para o câncer? É modulando o
sistema imune, né, principalmente
através da vitamina Dado
e eliminando os alimentos inflamatórios
e comendo limpo, né, comendo orgânico.
Isso vai deixar o sistema imune forte.
Certo? Então essa vacina dita vacina não
vai ser uma coisa para prevenir, tá?
Câncer, vai ser para tratar câncer.
Quando a pessoa obrigada a almoçar todos
os dias em restaurante, não tem como não
consumir os óleos hidrogenados?
Ah, depende, tá? Porque se você, por
exemplo, não comer fritura, você já vai
tá, eu não vou dizer eliminando porque a
palavra é forte, mas vai tá reduzindo
pelo menos 99% os óleos hidrogenados.
Sendo assim, o que é possível fazer?
Então, é o que possível fazer justamente
que eu acabei de falar, né? É cortar os
alimentos com fritura. É só você comer
salada, legume, né? E nada que foi frito
você usa, né?
Então, procura uma carne ou um frango
grelhado que não passou por óleo.
Procura uma carne ou frango que foi
assado, né, ou cozido. Come salada, come
legume, verdura, coloca o azeite de
oliva extra virgem, vai num self serv
que trabalha com azeite de
oliva extrav, né?
Ah, o legume, por exemplo, pegue no
vapor, se for possível. Então você vai
ter quear um salvo serve de boa
qualidade, tá? Então tudo que tem massa,
tudo que tem farinha de trigo empanado,
por exemplo, você vai ter óleo
hidrogenado, os óleos de soja que tem
hidrogenação, tá?
Não come salgadinhos,
nem molho industrializado, nem sobremesa
processada.
Conversa com o dono do restaurante ou
com ou com a nutricionista do
restaurante, tá bom?
Se você for cliente regular, você tem
até poder de
eh influir sobre a o cardápio, né?
Agora, se não tiver jeito nenhum de você
evitar esse contato com esse óleo
processado aí que tem que tem
hidrogenado, você procura compensar
usando ôega-3 de boa qualidade em casa,
vitamina E tocotenois, né?
Natural do urucum,
coisima Q10,
capricho fora do restaurante nos
alimentos antiinflamatórios com vegetais
coloridos, frutas vermelhas, cúcuma,
cucumina, gengibre, chás antioxidantes.
Tá bom?
Aqui está uma pergunta clara, completa e
profissional para você enviar o Dr. Alan
Dutter. A pessoa esqueceu de tirar essa
parte aqui do deve ter colocado no
chatt. Dr. Alan você poderia comentar
sobre caso de uma idosa de 72 anos que
apresenta sensação de estreitamento no
esôfago, dificuldade para engolir
principalmente alimentos sólidos e mais
duros em gasgos frequentes.
Quais seriam os principais exames para
investigar? Disfagia, já fez endoscopia,
mas não apresentou nada de importante.
Existe alguma suplementação, abordagem
integrativa? é um caso mais difícil, né?
A disfagia é bem comum idosos, tá?
Geralmente problema neurológico.
Também tem mulheres menopausadas uma
tendência a desenvolver uma dificuldade
de deglutição.
Então eu vou considerar aqui que a
endoscopia não mostrou nenhuma obstrução
mecânica evidente, certo? Nesse caso,
nós precisamos investigar a motilidade
do esôfago. Aí tem vários exames. Você
tem a video pluroscopia com deglutição,
também chamado de deglutograma.
Ele ajuda a visualizar em tempo real
como é que o alimento tá passando pela
farin até o esôfago, o estômago.
Pode usar também aquele e exame antigo
radiográfico, né? O Eed, tá? o ED, que é
o esôfago estômago doeno, que é um exame
radiográfico com báo, né?
Tem também a manometria isofágica de
alta resolução, que é um exame mais
moderno, avalia a contração e
coordenação dos músculos esofágicos.
Então, muitas vezes o idoso desenvolve
uma alteração funcional que o exame de
imagem, né, no caso endoscopia não vai
detectar.
também investigue se a pessoa não tem
hipocloridria, né, que vai comprometer a
progressão do bolo alimentar.
Então, primeira coisa seria remover o
glúten que atrapalha a motilidade do
isôfago, remover os derivados do leite,
pode utilizar a glutamina em pó,
5 a 10 g por dia para ajudar a regenerar
mucosa.
Zinco carnosina também muito bom para
ajudar na mocosa.
na faixa 75 mg por dia nas refeições.
Ah, vitamina A na forma de palmitato
ajuda.
Complexo B,
tá? Tudo isso são dicas interessantes.
Aí outra coisa que pode ser utilizada é
o licor DGL, tá? O licor DGL é bom para
essas coisas também.
Se tiver hipocoloridria confirmada, você
pode utilizar também o vinagre de maçã
ou cloridade betaína.
Dr. Alan, galinha poedeira que põe sem
ser fecundada.
Isso não é uma aberração na visão
integrativa?
Povo sem ser fecundado é perigo paraa
saúde?
Que eu saiba não, tá?
Na verdade, a galinha colocar sem a
presença do galo, né, não é uma
aberração, não. É um processo biológico
natural,
certo? É como se fosse uma ovulação
mensal nas mulheres.
Então, as galinhas atingem a maturidade
sexual, começam a produzir ovos
independentemente da fertilização,
pois isso faz parte do ciclo reprodutivo
normal, tá? Tanto que antigamente você
tinha as galinhas totalmente naturais,
né? Ovos são consumidos há milênios, né,
pelo ser humano. O galo só é necessário
quando tem realmente a necessidade de
que os ovos sejam fecundados para gerar
os pintinhos, né? Então não vejo
problema nenhum nesse processo
que seria fisiológico mesmo, tá?
Os ovos não fecundados são totalmente
seguros, é um dos alimentos mais
saudáveis da natureza.
Eles têm um alto valor nutritivo, é o
polivitamínico da natureza.
O que é importante pra qualidade
nutricional do ovo é a alimentação da
galinha, se ela cisca ou não, tá? É isso
que você tem que se preocupar,
tá? Como é que ela é tratada, quais são
as condições que essa galinha vive?
Então, ovos de galinhas criadas soltas
com alimentação natural e sem uso
excessivo de rações industrializadas,
sem hormônios, são muito superiores
nutricionalmente. OK?
Então, fica tranquilo quanto a isso.
Ã, acabamos aqui as perguntas e eu tô
bem cansado, pessoal. Então, eu vou já
vou encerrar. Deixa eu só interagir mais
um pouquinho com vocês
e vamos encerrar aqui.
Ah, deixa eu dar mais uns boas noites
aqui que eu acho que eu não dei boa
noite para Rosâela,
Carlos Roreve, Célina, esse acho que eu
dei sim.
Boa noite, Antônio Renato, Elizabeth
Badini,
Cristina Carol, Célia Spanger, Rick
Santinho, Danilo,
Ana Silva.
Essas manchas roxas que você tá falando
aí, elas são geralmente são
equimoses
de uma doença que não é grave, tá?
que se chama púrpura trobocitopênica
diopática, tá? Geralmente é isso, mas
tem que investigar, tá?
Ah, nenhuma das minhas está aí. Ué, por
que que não estaria? Você esqueceu de
colocar pergunta
porque tá de acordo com a planilha, tá?
que foi gerada do formulário.
Mas para mim só parece uma pergunta sua,
Antônio Renato. Tá só das galinhas
poideiras. Aí
são dois formulários. É isso.
Será que eu cometi essa gaf? Pera aí,
deixa eu ver aqui.
Pode ser, porque eu achei que a
automação que gerava o formulário tava
desligada.
Deixa eu ver ontem aqui. Hoje, hoje,
hoje, ontem.
Pode ser. Aconteceu isso.
Eh,
hoje, ontem, ontem, ontem.
Pera aí, gente, deixa eu abrir outro
documento, então. Mas se tinha um monte
de pergunta lá, eu vou deixar para
amanhã. Para amanhã não, para semana que
vem, né?
Porque
eu tô bem cansado.
Ontem, ontem, ontem. Cadê? Ver se eu
vejo 9 horas da manhã. É que o grupo tá
ficando grande, pessoal, e eu tô
perdendo as mensagens. Pera aí. Domingo,
ontem.
Pera aí, foi às 9. Geralmente às 9 que
solta, né? Deixa eu ver se soltou. Ih,
gente, foi exatamente isso.
A automação tava ligada e eu não vi.
Pera aí, deixa eu ver se eu consigo ver
aqui.
Eu não percebi, pessoal. Me desculpe.
Deu um, deu uma bola fora aqui.
Vamos ver.
Ixe, tem 20 perguntas aqui,
pessoal. Vamos fazer o seguinte, tá? Eh,
semana que vem eu não vou abrir, tá? Eu
não vou abrir questionário
e vou responder essas 20, tá?
E vou responder essas 20. Me desculpem,
realmente eu dei uma bobeada aqui.
Pera aí. Ah, link para planilha. Criar
nova planilha. Não tá aqui.
É que se tivesse pouca pergunta eu até
colocava aqui, gente, mas tem muita
pergunta aqui. Eu não, eu vou, vai ser
complicado responder isso agora.
Mas vamos lá, vou deixar já pronto para
semana que vem, tá bom? Pessoal,
você colocou o formulário no dia 10? Dia
10? Hoje não é dia 9, pessoal.
Hoje é dia 9.
Como assim? Dia 10.
Não entendi isso não. Ah, por isso
foi pouco doutro numa mora no min 20. É
verdade. Foi. Deu uma, dei uma bobeada
aqui.
Dei uma bobeada também.
Calma, pessoal. Vamos responder tudo
semana que vem, tá?
Beleza? Tá. Então vou fazer o seguinte,
eu vou lembrar, eu não vou soltar
formulário na semana que vem. Vou até
desligar a automação que faz isso aqui,
que eu deixei ela ligada, eu tinha eu
tinha achado que tava desligado.
E aí
quando for
semana que vem eu vou responder essas 20
perguntas que era para não ter sido
respondidas.
Pronto, já desliguei aqui para não gerar
duplicado de novo.
Ah, tá bom, Antônio. Certinho. Eu vou eu
vou responder a tua pergunta na semana
que vem, combinado?
Então, pessoal, muito obrigado pela
presença de vocês
e nos vemos na semana que vem, OK?
Aliás, esse domingo nós vamos fazer a
live do grupo dois, tá? Da comunidade lá
fechada do grupo
estudos avançados, tá bom? Nesse domingo
vão ter então a live dos estudos
avançados e na semana que vem a gente te
responde as perguntas que eu deixei de
responder hoje.
Pô, que que responde interrogação aqui,
Antônio? Que que você quiser com isso
aqui?
É porque a tua pergunta
tava no primeiro questionário, tá? E eu
realmente fiz essa bobagem. Eu gerei
dois eh questionários sem querer.
Tá bom? Então, as perguntas que eu
respondi agora foram do segundo
questionário
que foi gerado hoje e tinha um
questionário que tinha sido gerado ontem
já e eu não reparei. Foi isso. Tá bom,
ficou claro
isso? Super live. Vamos ter super live
no próximo domingo, tá bom?
Ã, deixa eu ver. Vocês fizeram aquele,
alguém queria ver aquele assunto meio
polêmico, né?
Eu preciso ver. A maioria respondeu que
queria ver aquele assunto polêmico, né?
Eu
tinha deixado fixado, mas desfixou aqui.
Tem que achar agora o a enquete.
Ã, não tô achando aqui agora.
Cadê a enquete? Mas eu lembro que a
enquete tava vencendo de falar desse
assunto.
Como é que eu acho isso aqui agora? Pera
aí. Tentar achar.
Pera aí.
Não, isso aqui foi do do fundo musical.
Deixa eu ver se eu acho aqui,
tá? A gente conversa sobre isso no grupo
depois, tá? Abraço para vocês, pessoal.
Até a semana que vem. Até domingo, quem
for do grupo de estudos avançados.
Beijo no coração.